a surprising strike against Israeli
soldiers near the Egyptian border
two found dead at a remote Outpost in
this rugged region
attacked in the early hours of Saturday
morning soon after a sizable drug stash
was seized
an operational incident in the bardelas
Battalion in the morning that happened
after another incident that happened at
night where the Battalion successfully
torted a large smuggle relatively in the
same area adjacent to it the Israeli
military's Southern Commander quickly on
the scene as part of the response
Egyptian authorities say a security
officer chasing drug smugglers had
crossed into Israel located later during
a search operation that individual
killed in an exchange of fire that left
a third Israeli soldier dead
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu called the event serious and
unusual insisting they would be
thoroughly investigated
both countries now collaborating on that
investigation a deadly incident that
Israeli officials suggest was far from
an accident
Villa Marx Al Jazeera West Jerusalem
China's defense minister has